das geht ja jetzt schon los dass sie bei
yoga kursen gefragt wird dadurch eine
yoga kurse anbieten oder pilates kurse
oder taekwondo das heißt was bleibt
einem sechsjährigen jetzt der deutsche
sport max schmeling sport also boxen und
ich esse nur noch deutsches essen und es
sind deutsche tattoos das ist ja der
feuchteste afd trauen
[Musik]
13 fragen hier kommt die erste
dreadlocks federschmuck oder hip hop ist
kulturelle aneignung diskriminierend
wenn er sagt ja er ja dann bitte auf dem
grünfeld positionieren wenn ihr sagt er
nein dann bitte aufs gelbe fällt und
bitte
[Musik]
ok jetzt wissen wir wo er steht aber wo
steht ihr in der musik beim karneval in
der mode oder beim essen die sogenannte
kulturelle aneignung gibt es ja
eigentlich schon seit immer auf die eine
oder andere weise aber die diskussion
darüber hat in den letzten jahren
ordentlich an tiefe und schärfe gewonnen
beispielhafter vorwurf billig oder
hierzulande schrien david würden sich
afroamerikanischer musik und mode
bedienen damit ordentlich asche
verdienen aber ohne jeglichen hinweis
auf kulturelle oder historischen
background die frage dahinter ist also
darf man zum beispiel hip hop einfach
als lifestyle leben ohne jegliche
reflexion woher diese musikrichtung
überhaupt kommt dürfen weiße dreadlocks
tragen darf ich mich an karneval als
geisha verkleiden eher nein sagen die
einen denn kulturelle aneignung zumal
beim marginalisierten gruppen kann eben
zur diskriminierung lehrer führen die
ich nach zu abend versuchen naja sagen
wir anderen kulturelle aneignung das gab
es ja schon immer in musik und mode und
beim essen usw das kann ja auch eine
form der wertschätzung sein bei 310
fragen suchen wir den kompromiss die
frage ist wie sieht er in dieser frage
aus und wie kommen die beiden gruppen am
ende des tages am ende dieser folge also
näher aufeinander zu wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren auf der grünen seite ja
kulturelle aneignung eher problematisch
oder auf der gelben müll eigentlich ganz
okay schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare also wenn ihr der gegenseite
in einem punkt zustimmt dann dürft ihr
gerne einen schritt nach vorne gehen und
wenn ihr sagt na ja grundsätzlich finde
ich das was du sagst gar nicht so
schlecht aber da erzählst du wirklich
völligen quatsch dann dürft ihr auch
gerne einen schritt zurückgehen mein
ziel ist es natürlich am ende möglichst
viele von euch in die mitte zu bewegen
damit wir eben in richtung kompromiss
vielleicht sogar konsens uns bewegen das
ist ja das ziel der ganzen sendung 13
fragen hier kommt frage nummer 2 und die
geht an angelina angelina du bist ja
tätig in einem friseursalon und du
beschäftigst sich auch zum beispiel mit
afrikanischer schlecht kunst heutzutage
wird man vielleicht bereits sagen das
hast du jahrelang gemacht und dann
er gab sich irgendwann ein shitstorm
über dich was ist passiert also ich
praktiziere seit 17 jahren auto
zentrische ha fläche kunst und bin eben
auch spezialisiert auf diese
gruppierungen und ich bin mit kaviar
nnern groß geworden quasi von klein auf
und war sehr sehr tief in dieser kultur
drin verwurzelt und ich würde sagen seit
56 jahren ging dann diese debatte um
kulturelle aneignung los und das waren
das erste mal dass ich ja mit so einer
gewalt sage ich mal mit diesem thema
konfrontiert wurde das war dann der
vorwurf na ja der vorwurf war dass ich
quasi eine kultur beklauen würde und
mich dann daran in diesem kontext in
meinem beruflichen rahmen bereichern
würde ohne quasi in der kultur etwas
zurückzugeben ich habe das gefühl dass
von beiden seiten
sehr viel schmerz einfach einfach sehr
viel schmerz vorherrscht und sehr viel
vorwurfs haltung und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir da ja einen aus diesem
emotionalen ein bisschen raus finden
sozusagen und mehr in sachliche kommt
denn ich finde die probleme liegen
wesentlich tiefer wenn wir über
rassismus sprechen als in irgendeiner
frisur showdown
würdest du wird bei ihr im friseursalon
der die haare machen lassen
asbeck verlierer was müsste denn
passieren dass du sagst hey
respektvolles ich gehe zu dir in dem
salon weil ich den eindruck habe du
kennst dich aus mit dem was du tust und
du kannst auch den background ich für
mich kann mir das jetzt gar nicht
vorstellen dass ich sage ich geh zu
jemanden der
nicht black es nicht auf color ist was
ich problematisch finde wenn eine person
einen haarsalon eröffnet in dem
afrikanische schwarze frisuren
als service zu zeigen angeboten werden
ist dass ich an die menschen denken die
das schon jahrelang machen schon von
kindheit auf gelernt haben und einfach
nicht die gleichen zugangsmöglichkeiten
haben dass das problematische für mich
warum ist das so ein
tiefgründiges ding die strukturen in
denen wir uns bewegen die sind per se
rassistisch geprägt und haare wie sie
jetzt tragen wir diese jetzt sehen waren
oder sind immer noch ein riesenthema im
sinne von kriege ich den job kriege ich
die wohnung werde ich als sympathisch
gelesen oder nicht das sind alles themen
und wenn dann eben zb eine weiße person
sagt hey ich mache jetzt den breaking
salon auf ist per se nicht das problem
nun das was alles mit dahin einhergeht
das ist das problem dass eben die
gleiche person die sagen wir mal und
sein kind an mit schwarzen auch groß
geworden ist wie du es vielleicht auch
bis dass das mag sein und gleichzeitig
bekommt diese
frisörin zum beispiel nicht die gleichen
chancen
vielleicht nicht die gleichen kunden mit
den gleichen ressourcen um effekte
gleichwertige arbeit zu machen wie du
sie tust und das ist eben das problem
also wenn ich dich nicht verstanden habe
solange das grundsätzliche system von
machtmissbrauch und rassismus nicht
geändert wird würdest du jetzt zum
beispiel in einem weißen rating salon
nicht gerne kunden seien ja wenn es sich
aber ändern würde würde sich das
vielleicht auch wieder ändern tja also
ist klingt nach einer utopie meiner
meinung nach auf dich total gern
irgendwie hin steuer oder hinarbeite und
gleichzeitig ist es einfach nicht der
status quo hatten ein ganz
nachvollziehen ich kann nachvollziehen
was tragen sagte mit dem mit dem das
system so ist wie es ist das ist
diskriminierung gibt dass man wenn man
schwarzen braunes was auch immer also
wie oc dass meine wohnung nicht bekommen
dass man arbeitsplatz nicht bekommen
dass man diskriminiert wird das ist so
das stelle ich selbst auch in meinem
leben fest aber die lösung kann doch
nicht sein dass ich dann selbst mich auf
solche mechanismen zurück ziehen und
sagen und deswegen darf jemand der weiß
ist kein kleinen salon ausmachen und
rastalocken machen genauso wie das geht
ja nicht nur diejenigen die das machen
sondern auch diejenigen die kunden sind
also deswegen darf zum beispiel jemand
der weiß es sich keine rastalocken
machen lassen von hieraus kann sich
dieter aus deggendorf rastalocken machen
lassen genauso wie angelina
selbstverständlich einen salon machen
darf das heißt ich finde es falsch nach
dieser diagnose dass diese gesellschaft
ist wie sie ist dann sich zurück zu
berufen sagen und deswegen gehe ich
nicht so jemanden wie ihr das finde ich
falsch weil damit verhärten wir diese
fronten anstatt dass wir sie aufbrechen
ja es gibt ganz viel wo angegriffen wird
wo diskriminiert wird was falsch ist und
ich finde auch gut dass wir überhaupt
darüber reden aber ich würde allen die
sich sofort angegriffen fühlen sagen
leute stellt euch mal ein bisschen
zurück und schaut warum leute was tun
wenn sie es tun mit der absicht zu
verletzen ist es verletzend wenn sie
selber tun weil sie eigentlich
wertschätzen oder weil es einfach schön
finden ist dass keine verletzung im
grunde genommen auch wenn ihr euch
selbst persönlich vielleicht verletzt
fühlt wie und wo fängt denn für dich
kulturelle aneignung im negativen sinne
an also was sind deine erfahrung damit
auch ja kultureller aneignen beginnt für
mich da wenn menschen betroffen vernetzt
werden und da liegt die deutungshoheit
auch nicht bei leuten die nicht
betroffen sind der fox als trend ist ja
gerade sehr prominent und der ist für
mich besonders verletzend warum weil
weiße menschen sich diese augen vor
meine augen vom einfach schminken können
ohne mit den alltäglichen
diskriminierungserfahrungen leben zu
müssen ich kann am nächsten tag nicht
meine augen form ablegen für mich ist
mein aussehen kein trend so und wenn ich
sowas sehe dann denke ich mir ich wurde
in meiner kindheit am laufenden band
wegen meiner augen diskriminiert mir
wurde schnitts auge und sonstwas gegen
den kopf geworfen und jetzt kommt da
eine kita geht oder eine weiße nina aus
der nachbarschaft schmiegt sich die
augen und das ist eben das problem die
mensch nicht die ganz gesellschaft
entscheidend was cool ist was trend ist
was erlaubt ist das ist nicht okay und
ja ich wäre dafür das ist einfach
gelassen wird also wenn du in deiner
kindheit gehänselt wurde ist es da nicht
ehrlich ganz cool das jetzt asiatische
augen plötzlich
dass die leute das haben wollen
also ich meine ist doch eher umgekehrt
nicht mal so ein problem wenn sie auch
mal in
endlicher afrikanischen gesellschaften
oder in indien oder den asiatischen
ländern alle so aussehen wollen wie
weiße
hollywoodstars und jetzt also anfangen
entweder ihre gesicht weiß zu schminken
oder irgendwelche krems zu nehmen oder
versuchen sich die augen zu vergrößern
also sozusagen das das was du hast zum
schönheitsideal wird war eine kann doch
eigentlich besseres passieren clip in
bayern was passiert dann normalerweise
im oktober oktoberfest der thailänder
kommt auch bangkok am franz josef strauß
flughafen an mit der thailänderin und
das erste was sie tun ist sich eine
lederhose anziehen und ein dirndl
sagt irgendjemand in bayern das
kulturelle an allgemein dabei ist stolz
darauf weil er das als bestätigung
seiner lebensweise empfindet sondern als
ganz nach hinten gelaufen als angesetzt
hat
ich bin komplett raus weil ein aspekt
der jetzt gerade auch tatsächlich schon
passiert wo ich finde wohl nochmal
richtig deutlich wird wie problematisch
diese aneignung ist das nämlich aus dass
wir
hier ist die gute kämen kim kardashian
sich jetzt wieder zum beispiel ihren po
verkleinern hat lassen oder wieder zu
ursprungsform zurückgekommen ist miley
cyrus hat sich ihre ästhetik hat jetzt
ihre raps phase ihrer hip hop phase
sozusagen hinter sich und distanziert
sich auch von hiphop um eben in der
country branche wieder ein bisschen
größer rauszukommen oder mehr anklang zu
finden und genau das signalisiert hat
okay stilisiere diese kulturelle
aneignung zu meinen gunsten wenn es mir
passt wenn es mir gerade für mich gerade
musikalisch künstlerisch mir in die
karten spielt und jetzt wo ich gemerkt
habe
den right wing americans gefällt
irgendwie meine hip hop anlehnung nicht
so sehr odernähe nicht so sehr und ich
brauche die aber und sage jetzt hab ich
habe jetzt die phase durch und
präsentiere mich auch von der ästhetik
wieder weisser also da ist wirklich klar
es gibt diesen umschwung zu gunsten von
auch am finanziellen profit okay das ist
ein argument für dich also der kommerz
in der missbrauch einer anderen kultur
aus aus aus hellem grün ja das ist für
dich ein wesentlicher könnte es und ich
versuche die zu verstehen könnte es ein
szenario geben in dem miley cyrus ihre
rap phase weiter kultiviert und
irgendwann glaubhaft macht ich finde
diese kultur so großartig ich will jetzt
immer teil dieser kultur sein und sie
weiterleben könntest du dir vorstellen
dass das möglich wäre bei einer miley
cyrus weil ich kann es mir sogar bei mir
nicht vorstellen dass ich zum beispiel
schwarze person authentisch eine afro
amerikanische rap kultur repräsentieren
könnte denn ich finde ehrlich gesagt
auch deutschen rap in der hinsicht oft
fragwürdig denn da wo diese kultur
wirklich herkommt die umstände in denen
menschenleben durch gelebt haben die
wurden dann auf eine art und weise
glorifiziert die einfach auch gar nicht
der realität entsprochen haben und ich
habe mich in letzter zeit viel mit
menschen unterhalten die wirklich in
projects in der wirklichen hund gelebt
haben und dachte mir auf gar keinen fall
würde ich
als fan also ich habe man schon ganz
schön wurzeln wenn in bayern und nrw
groß geworden ich habe noch nie in
meinem leben ein projekt eine höhere ttc
oder noch nie in dieser prekären
situation gelebt wo ich tagtäglich für
gar nichts auf der straße erschossen
werden kann und das ist die kultur aus
der eben rap kommt das ist kein spaß das
ist nicht cool dass es nicht witzig das
wo es herkommt und wenn miley cyrus das
verstehen würde glaube ich nicht denn
sie ist wirklich verstehen würde glaube
ich nicht dass sie sich versuchen würde
in einem rap kontext zu präsentieren
denn nicht mal ich würde das tun das ist
interessant dass wir nur hiphop experten
neben dir stehen haben alex weißer
kartoffeln dürfen nach der konsequenz
eigentlich keine bleibt mehr machen
bestimmt dazu also ich würde gerne diese
dürfen es geht eher darum zeugen bild
cream ihren dass sie sich kulturell
elemente an eigenen dürfen
jetzt keine verbote aber du fühlst dich
problematisch also ich persönlich bin
fan von zu vielen weißen künstlern und
künstlerinnen um das so unterschreiben
zu können ich stehe auf der grünen seite
weil ich persönlich sehr froh darüber
bin dass über kulturelle aneignungen
endlich
diskutiert wird auch in meinem umfeld
diskutiert wird ich bin eben ein weißer
zizmann ich profitiere von einer
ursprünglich schwarzen marginalisierten
kulturform nämlich hip hop verdiene
damit mein geld und es ist das mindeste
dass ich mich nach jahren in denen ich
das leider nicht gemacht habe weil ich
mit dieser diskussion erst über die
jahre bewusst gemacht wurde
darüber nachdenke und credits gebe eben
auch und und immer mal wieder irgendwie
auch diesen weg zum wagen zurück zu den
wurzeln wo kommt hip hop eigentlich her
auch wenn natürlich irgendwie 90 prozent
der rapper innen mit denen ich mich
irgendwie beschäftigen oder die ich zum
interview treffen irgendwie weiß sind so
wurzeln liegen woanders ich habe lange
gedacht okay hip hop finde ich cool ja
hip hop king der welt ist eminem ein
weißer hip hop kings und deutschland
sind aggro berlin so ne also mit diesem
hip hop verständnis bin ich irgendwie
aufgewachsen und das hat mir auch mtv
irgendwie so suggeriert und erst im
laufe der jahre und durch diese
aufkommende diskussion um kulturelle
aneignung habe ich mich darin irgendwie
ein stückweit reflektiert weiß natürlich
ja
ich bin noch nicht am ende dieses
reflexionsprozess angelangt ist nicht
hip hop genau das paradebeispiel dafür
was entstehen kann wenn man aneignet und
ich meine wir haben ja also ist muss er
noch viel mehr entstanden auch die ganze
soulmusik rock'n roll all das in ihren
verschiedenen variationen die wir jetzt
haben eine kulturelle vielfalt die sich
entwickelt hat ja so mit einer großen
gemeinsamkeit der hand alles im prinzip
marginalisierte auch teilweise die sagen
protest getriebene absolut uns
kulturform die allesamt von weißen
dominanz kulturen ja wiederum angeeignet
wurden ja deswegen glaube ich es ist
nicht optimal gelaufen und da ist noch
sehr viel luft nach oben ich denke
gerade wenn wir jetzt über hiphop
sprechen dann wäre es ein guter ansatz
zum beispiel zu sagen gut also
bildungsarbeit muss stattfinden credits
geben wie kann das aussehen im fall von
hiphop hol dir vielleicht nicht eine
schwarze tänzerin die irgendwo vierte
reihe im background tanz so sondern
macht mal ein feature mit einem künstler
vielleicht der der der tatsächlich die
marginalisierte position hat und die
perspektive und daran eben mit
profitieren kann also damit geld
verdienen kann also zb in meinem fall
ich bin hip hop journalist ich habe mir
vorgenommen mehr eben selber zu lernen
über die roots dieser kultur und darüber
eben auch aufzuklären auf den
plattformen die mir zur verfügung stehen
aber du hast auch wieder den punkt ins
feld geführt nämlich machtstrukturen
erstmal sich dessen gewahr werden und
sie ernst nehmen und versuchen sie
aufzubrechen indem man marginalisierte
menschen mit reinhold über den features
jetzt genau und eben nicht nur solo
kommt reinhold weil ja irgendwie mit
reinhold passiert irgendwas im
hintergrund sondern irgendwie wirklich
als protagonistinnen mit reinholen jan
kannst du mit dieser argumentation mit
gehen dass du sagst mensch wir werden
uns dessen bewusster wir klar bildung
sagt er bei jeder sendung am ende wir
brauchen mehr bildung das stimmt schon
arbeiten der aufmerksamkeit erzeugen
wissen erzeugen und dann im wissen wer
machtstrukturen besser damit umgehen
können also letztlich ist ja das was
schon auch gesagt also eigentlich findet
sie is wrapped weil es eben aus dem
ghetto kommt eine sache schwarzer leute
und da sollten die weißen die finger von
lassen
und wenn ich das weiterdenken muss ich
aber sagen das gilt auch für die
konsumenten und das sind bittere bittere
nachricht für alle die mit rapmusik
millionäre geworden die die noch
millionäre geworden sind ist für die es
gut aber die noch millionäre werden
wollen ist schlecht wenn also mein
publikum nur noch dann besteht aus
schwarzem leuten und ich sage mal
diejenigen schon mal rausnehmen die die
haupt consumer gruppe in amerika sind
nämlich alle weißen mittelschicht kinder
dann wird es jedenfalls finnlands schon
länger ich frage mich welches
gesellschaftsbild steckt dahinter
ich meine und unsere kultur besteht aus
aneignung die kartoffel obwohl wir jetzt
kartoffeln genannt werden kommt nicht
aus deutschland wird für viele leute
eine große überraschung sein nein sie
kommen aus südamerika und wenn ich ja
richtig verstanden habe dann ist deine
auffassung von kulturell aneignung dazu
könnte dazu neigen das wir kulturelle
vielfalt aufgeben richtig verstanden ich
finde man muss ein bisschen gucken dass
die spalten in denen wir halt
argumentieren und diskutieren irgendwie
so ein bisschen ähnlich bleiben weil
sonst kann die so gut auf gar keinen
grünen länder und ich würde mich total
freuen wenn es uns gelingen würde auf
den grünen dazu kommen denn ziel finde
ich es nicht zu sagen jeder muss seine
eigenen spalte bleiben sondern im
idealfall lernen wir alle voneinander
von in unterschiedlichen kulturen aber
mit welcher haltung und mit den macht
positionen und privilegien die
unterschiedliche leute eben auch haben
geht einfach auch eine gewisse
verantwortung mit einher ich möchte aber
noch mal was zu den augen sagen zum
beispiel manchmal gedacht das ist mir
sehr wichtig weil ich finde ich kann
diese verletztheit total nachvollziehen
dass man diskriminiert wurde es mal
blöde sprüche und begriffe die ich gar
nicht wiederholen möchte gehört hat und
so weiter ich habe mein leben lang immer
wieder sprüche gehört wegen meiner
hautfarbe ja möchte ich auch gar keine
begriffe nennen aber dann kann man sich
vorstellen kann wenn man braune haut hat
bekommt man sprüche zu hören in deiner
logik müsste ich jetzt sagen jeder weiß
der sich point der sich sonst macht
etwas problematisches finde ich nicht in
ordnung weil ich habe braune haut ich
erlebt dass ihr entscheidet euch frei
euch zu bräunen darf man nicht mehr das
finde ich absurd natürlich dass sich
jeder freuen es ist doch schön wenn
jemand dieses ideal übernimmt und
trotzdem kritisiere ich diejenigen die
mich beleidigen wegen meiner hautfarbe
das heißt diejenigen die dich beleidigt
haben wir in deiner augen form dass du
die kritisiert würde ich sofort bei dir
und wenn die sich jetzt auch noch die
augen so formen würden wieder schminken
würden wie du sie hast würde ich sie
auch kritisiert sagen aha vorher hast du
mich so und so genannt und jetzt macht
es selbst das bin ich ja so richtig aber
grundsätzlich zu sagen das wäre
problematisch dass menschen die eben
nicht ostasiatische gelesen werden dass
die jetzt also sich die augen sofort das
finde ich also absolut in ordnung ich
würde das auch als vermieter doch klingt
doch plausibel das problem ist zum einen
es wird auch irgendwas de produziert
also nicht jeder asiatische oder
asiatisch genesene personen hat zum
beispiel solche augen aber wenn man sich
als andere sich genau gleich bei dieser
fox als trend der es hat das ist genau
klar definiert wie die augen geschminkt
werden und wenn sich an jetzt diese
augen schminken und sie sehen und andere
sehen das und denken ja das sieht ja
asiatisch außerdem wird eben die systeme
type von asiatisch gelesenen augen
reproduziert und dass das ist das
problematisch daran wer jetzt auch im
globus sozusagen nur den fox ein trend
ja mein gott dann haben wir alle
besseres zu tun als uns jetzt um diesen
fox ein trend alleine zu kümmern aber es
geht einfach um die vielzahl es geht
darum uns geht um verkleidungen es geht
darum dass ich mich eben kommerziell
wesentlich besser darstellen kann
positionieren kann es geht noch mal also
wir reden wirklich im lebensraum den
manche menschen einfach verwehrt
bekommen und andere dafür über wieder
gepriesen werden es ist so ein riesen
vielzahl es ist genau so verkehrt zum
beispiel sich eben als kz insassen zu
verkleiden warum weil einfach so ein
riesengebäude damit einher geht mit der
geschichte die sich die damit einfach
ein herangegangen ist und da wir
verstanden haben wie schrecklich das war
warum sollte es witzig sein sich so zu
verkleiden denn was da drin sind es
einfach menschen so karikiert werden ich
würde gerne wissen verstehst du den
punkt auch das wäre nun der drastisches
aber extremes beispiel
etwas anderes also na gut es geht um
marginalisierte gruppen unterschieden
es ist ein unterschied ob ich mich als
american wo
als sklave verkleinern ich gehe als
sklave auf einer party oder würde ich
mal sagen also sozusagen als leidens
figur das ist komisch das kostüm ist ja
nun was anderes als ob ich mich als
indianer in diesem fall häuptling oder
pirat oder das erste mal dass es
interessant warum ist es ein unterschied
als sklave und native american zum
beispiel in der der der indianer heute
nun mal glaube sieht sich
jetzt nicht notwendigerweise als
leitfigur es gibt sehr viele leute die
sehr stolz auf ihren auf ihre auf ihre
herkunft sind
ich habe die ganze diskussion um den
indianerhäuptling nicht verstanden
ehrlich gesagt also ich habe zehn jahren
amerika gelebt es gibt kein indianer in
amerika der an dem wort indianer
anschluss nimmt es gibt den inneren
specialist geben vielleicht hast du es
nicht betroffen aber es gibt also ist
kein in amerika kein auch unter den
indianer kein problematischer begriff
ist das heißt ob ich in national
congress ist die oberste standes
versammlung der der region amerika so
das ist das ist natürlich glaubt eine
vorstellung wiederum von weiß gar nicht
wo das herkommt von grünen parteitags
gibt ein schwieriger begriff sein denn
wir versuchen rückgängig zu machen den
prozess der globalisierung des
kapitalismus da kann man darüber klagen
dass ist natürlich so dass unser system
besteht daraus dass wir wenn wir uns
wollen die andere dinge aneignen so und
was weiß ich so eigenartig finde was ist
die alternative das geht ja jetzt schon
los dass sie bei yoga kursen gefragt
wird dadurch eine yoga kurse anbieten
oder pilates kurse oder taekwondo dh was
bleibt einem sechsjährigen jetzt der
deutsche sport max schmeling sport also
boxen und ich esse nur noch deutsches
essen weil das und sommer deutscher tust
was immer das ist also sagen der anker
aus hamburg wo ich herkomme aus der
hansestadt das ist sozusagen das ist ja
der feuchteste afd trauen also es heißt
jeder bleibt in sozusagen seiner kultur
was immer das heißt und da gehe ich
nicht mehr mit ich will nicht innerhalb
die kultur leben entschuldigen dass ich
noch mal zurückkommen zu ich weil ich
noch nicht ganz verstanden habe wo der
unterschied für dich liegt also native
americans indigener die ja nachweislich
jahrhundertelang unterdrückt
abgeschlachtet und so weiter wurden da
findest du es unproblematisch dich als
ein solcher zu verkleiden aber bei den
sklaven in anführungszeichen die eine
ähnliche leidensgeschichte hinter sich
haben siehst du findest du es
problematisch warum was ist der
unterschied was ist das kriterium wir
versuchen nachzuvollziehen wo ist wo
könnte eine grenze verlaufen die grenze
ist beim ich weiß aber gar nicht also
will ich sagen wir als klar weiß ich mit
bitte jetzt das würde ich mal sagen wir
mitbieten und
mir irgendwie weist euch nochmal
aufgeschminkten
der fantasie keine grenzen gesetzt
streamen von einer auspeitschung gehe
ich auf eine auf den kostüm party und
welchem punkt zu machen sodass
eigentlich lustig zu machen darüber dass
menschen bitteres unrecht erlitten haben
oder furchtbar gelitten haben zusammen
also wenn das dann kategorie ahl anderer
andere geschichte als sagen wir mal mich
zu verkleiden als eine andere
volksgruppe als tiroler meinetwegen oder
als bayer könnte das nachvollziehen ich
hätte eine rückfrage und wenn du an
einen in die ankunft an kostümen von dem
indigenen menschen denken woran denkst
du wahrscheinlich an federn am kopf
schlug also was kinder sich also was wir
uns natürlich auch allerdings kennen ja
sowieso ist gut kannst ja das gibt's ja
muss ich weiß nicht ob du mal jemals in
einem in dem in einem in dem
indianischen reservaten amerika gab
spritzgießer text zu sagen ist ja der
teil schon ausgestellt haben die
wahrnehmung die man hier habt also ich
muss davor jetzt nicht nach amerika
reisen sondern das was man ja bei einem
so genannten indianerkostüm sieht das
sind ja die irgendwie kopfschmuck federn
usw und das ist doch genau die form das
ist doch nichts fast nichts anderes als
bei schuhen als wunden von
auspeitschungen weil
indigene völker wurden aufgrund dessen
ermordet weil sie anders ausgesehen weil
sie diesen federn waren jahren an
verboten dass das dass mir heute davon
profitieren können dass wir wissen dass
es sowas überhaupt gibt war ganz allein
die arbeit von indigenen menschen die
das über generationen hinweg überliefert
haben und es geschafft haben über
liefern und deswegen ist für mich da das
ist für mich das klar also das ist für
mich sehr vergleichbar was ist mit den
thailändern chinesen sonst was die zum
oktoberfest kommen und sich lederhosen
anziehen und dürrn will die frauen und
weiter das ist auch kulturell aneignung
dürfen sie das und ist es in ordnung
natürlich
schauen wir was sagst du denn
die chinesische familie sitzt dem
oktoberfest fährt und sich lederhosen
anziehen auch kulturelle aneignung ganz
klar ist das problematisch oder nicht
denn die asiatische familie zum
oktoberfest geht und sich bayerische
traditionelle tracht anzieht es ist
deshalb etwas anderes weil
einfach die geschichte die dahinter
steht jetzt von ich sag mal bayern
soweit ich weiß ich bin auch in bayern
groß geworden teilweise
erinnere ich mich jetzt nicht dass in
jüngster vergangenheit oder rentenalter
vergangenheit bayern fast glasboden
unterjocht wurden oder sich jemals ein
anderes volk oder die
mehrheitsgesellschaft über bayern lustig
gemacht hat dass bayern deswegen keinen
zugang zu bildung bekommen wenn man
irgendwie julius
engelberger heißt oder julian
engelberger heißt es sein bayrischer
nachname die klauen oder sie wollen wir
hier nicht haben das hat mich
stattgefunden und also etwas anderes ist
dass wir dieses argument für dich also
noch mal zusammen bayern sind aktuell
nicht in der regel nicht rassismen
unterworfen wie es andere
bevölkerungsgruppen sind deswegen ist
die kulturelle aneignung der bayerischen
kultur weniger problematisch als bei
anderen kulturen das kann für mich
überhaupt gar kein maßstab sache denn
ich habe viele jahre in pakistan gelebt
als korrespondent ich habe ja wurzeln in
indien und pakistan habe dort als
korrespondent auch gelebt und wie wir
wissen war der indische subkontinent
jahrhundertelang von dritten cologne
alice kolonialisiert als ich dort gelebt
habe habe ich sehr viele briten weiße
briten kennen gelernt in pakistan in
indien die dort als entwicklungshelfer
waren geschäftsleute diplomaten
journalisten alles mögliche und diese
weißen menschen frauen wie männer haben
dort auch indische pakistanische
kleidung getragen schall war khamis
solange das knie langes hemd und so eine
prognose sieht so ein bisschen für java
mäßig aus haben also im grunde genommen
die kleidung der menschen übernommen die
sie jahrhundertelang kolonialisiert
haben und das hat niemand als
problematisch sondern im gegenteil ist
es ein zeichen der wertschätzung die
haben sich heute so bewegt wie viele
andere menschen auch also sie haben sich
sozusagen eingefügt ich fand das auch
ein paar das auch als etwas gutes und
schönes man könnte man endlich sagen ist
kultur ahnung was sagt ihr euch so zu
kleiden ihr habt uns jahrhundertelang
unterdrückt ausgebeutet ihr sagt immer
noch hier als entwicklungshelfer und
drehten teilweise auf wie die herrscher
über uns aber nein die menschen sehen
dass eigentlich überwiegend als als
wertschätzung also nur weil jetzt jemand
sich diskriminiert fühlt das kann für
mich nicht das kriterium sein gleichwohl
nehme ich diese diskriminierung oder
dieses verletztheit war und höre drauf
also die motivation der wertschätzung
die jetzt das beispiel ist ja ist ja ein
interessantes beispiel du hast ja gesagt
das sind quasi die ehemaligen
kolonialherren die er sich jetzt immer
hier noch teilweise als herrscher
aufführen und als zeichen der
wertschätzung kleiden sie sich aber so
ähnlich und offenbar finden die menschen
dass vor ort wie du es erlebt hast sogar
positiv habe ich richtig verstanden was
sagt ihr dazu ist das überhaupt denkbar
in eurem in eurer logik also ich fand
die umfrage total spannend wirklich von
denen pakistani dann zu hören unter sich
ganz ehrlich wie sie das tatsächlich
finden denn es klingt für mich danach
als würden sie immer noch semi
kolonisiert werden oder immer noch von
den auswirkungen der kolonisation die
dynamiken da immer noch so schwingen und
da frage ich mich inwieweit fühlen die
sich überhaupt frei dann dem deutschen
reportern den deutschen korrespondenten
et cetera dann wirklich zu sagen du ganz
ehrlich und das ding ist mit den ganzen
ist das ding mit den ganzen ist mit ist
ja auch dass viele menschen die auch
marginalisiert sind und selbst davon
betroffen sind erstmal lernen müssen
dass das überhaupt der stand der dinge
ist denn nur weil es vielleicht eine
andere person gibt die zum beispiel so
aussehen wie ich und sagt ja mein hobby
der nennt mich das an bord für mich ist
das vollkommen in ordnung so am ende des
tages muss natürlich jede person ist für
sich selbst auch klar kriegen
gleichzeitig
viele von uns müssen erst mal verstehen
wie die es wenn überhaupt wirken und nur
weil jetzt eine person zwei personen
30.5 sagen dass das in ordnung ist
bedeutet das nicht dass es in ordnung
ist ich mein es waren 19 45 vieler dinge
in der mehrheitsgesellschaft in ordnung
von den menschen gesprochen haben die
aber einfach de facto aus der heutigen
perspektive überhaupt nicht in ordnung
waren das ist nicht der indikator
unbedingt etwas nach hinten gelaufen
warum also weil ich diese argumentation
wirklich absurd finde man möchte man
sollte erst mal hören wie die pakistan
aber nun pakistaner intern reden darüber
erstens ich bin selbst auch pakistan
pakistanische wurst und fühle mich auch
als solcher vielleicht zu einem
kleineren anteil aber als als deutscher
aber natürlich bin ich das auch und das
klingt ja fast schon so nur weil du dann
findest das nehmen wir nicht ernst ja
und weil du darfst als wertschätzung
findet in wahrheit banken die ja noch
ganz anders und wenn sie anders denken
sondern das als wertschätzung empfinden
dann sind sie noch nicht gebildet genug
noch nicht sozusagen erzogen genug
sondern die sind immer noch in wahrheit
kolonialisiert und das finde ich das
finde ich ehrlich gesagt eine
unverschämtheit also dass es geht
überhaupt gar nicht sondern
selbstverständlich
respektiere ich wenn viele pakistaner
und pakistaner sagen ich habe finde das
als wertschätzung und dann möchte ich
nicht dass man den leuten sagt sonja
sagt du bist dann immer noch
kolonialisiert also das geht nicht wie
geht's euch aktuell habt ihr für euch
eine sinnhafte lösung gefunden könnt ihr
diese oder diese argumente besser
nachvollziehen schreibt gerne in die
kommentare ich würde ganz gerne mal kurz
angelina wieder mit ins boot holen weil
wir haben jetzt länger nichts von dir
gehört wie geht's dir gerade also das
was hier eben gesagt wurde dieser
erfahrung mit eigentlich wird es als
wertschätzung sehen diese erfahrung habe
ich auch gemacht weil als ich mich mit
dieser kulturellen aneignung beschäftigt
habe bin ich selber auch nach afrika
gereist ich war in westafrika ich war
dort in den salon ich habe dort in den
schwarzen familien gelebt am leben
teilgenommen und auch mich mit diesen
dingen befasst und auch erfragt wie es
dort gesehen wird und dort ist dieses
thema überhaupt nicht bekannt also die
menschen haben sich fast schon beleidigt
gefühlt als ich nur ansatzweise das
geschildert habe und konnten das nicht
nachempfinden und so habe ich für mich
den schluss daraus gezogen dass es
wirklich ein europäisches problem ist
also ein eurozentristisch es problem ich
führe auch kurse durch also ich
unterrichte quasi auch friseure die
bereits in der branche tätig sind in
besonderen bereichen in dieser schiene
die sich dafür interessieren und
weiterbilden möchten und ich selber
beschäftige auch menschen die aus afrika
kommen diverse kulturen also sowohl die
amerikaner als auch afrikaner ist es
irgendwie alles bei uns dabei und es ist
wirklich wie so eine art familiäre
atmosphäre in der wir uns über genau
diese themen austauschen und sehr gesund
austauschen und diese ganze debatte also
dieses gespräch und was dürfen wir was
dürfen wir nicht ich finde da kratzen
wir immer noch sehr an der oberfläche
und da würde ich mir zum beispiel
wünschen dass man sich irgendwie
mechanismen überlegt wie kann man anti
rassismus arbeit in den schulen
betreiben wie können wir aufhören an der
oberfläche zu kratzen und mehr in die
tiefe zu gehen und wirklich
lösungsorientiert einfach zu leben und
zu arbeiten und nicht ständig einander
zu beschimpfen mit vorwürfen und so
weiter so kommen wir einfach nicht zum
ergebnis dass war eigentlich ist in
dieser veranstaltung auch mal sehen wie
wir aber immerhin du hast jetzt immerhin
geschafft dass ihr drei so zaghaft nach
vorne gelaufen seid wieso eigentlich zum
beispiel angelina als auch davon
gesprochen hast dass du eben auch kurse
gibst dass du menschen anstellt aus
jamaika afrika et cetera dachte ich mir
wie cool wäre es wenn nur sozusagen das
privileg einer hast da gut vernetzt
vielleicht auch dies gäste haben uns
noir menschen jobs zu geben wie cool
wäre es sich da einfach die frage zu
stellen ich lese dich als als weiße frau
warum muss ich jetzt als weiße frau
schwarzen menschen
zeigen erklären wie sie mit ihren haaren
umgehen können was ist an der struktur
noch machbar was kann verändert werden
wie kann ich meine privilegien meine
zugänge vielleicht teilen um anderen
menschen auch zugang zu diesen
ressourcen zu geben dass die dieses
know-how selber strukturell verbreiten
können denn das ist ja auch das problem
das dahintersteht
ja so das thema verantwortung wie gehe
ich mit den privilegien die ich habe und
wie kann ich anderen menschen die
weniger privilegiert sind einfach daran
teilhaben lassen um eben einfach
strukturell eine veränderung
herbeizuführen
denn es geht eher darum dass wir eine
schieflage von hunderten von jahren
versuchen einfach lediglich
gleichzusetzen es geht nicht darum dass
irgendjemand wegen nehmen an was
wegnehmen möchte sondern wir versuchen
immer noch eine schieflage einfach
gerade zu rücken ja ich verstehe was du
sagst und ich bin mir auch über diese
privilegien absolut bewusst und ich
finde dass ich nach meinem ermessen
bereits alles mögliche in meiner macht
stehende tue um der kultur was
zurückzugeben sei es durch integration
von schwarzen personen die bei uns
arbeiten sei es durch credits dann am
ende des tages ich bediene ja schwarz
also ich bediene natürlich andersfarbige
ich lehne ja nicht einen kunden ab weil
er jetzt weiß ist so aber ich versuche
quasi alles was in meiner macht steht
und meine ressourcen meine privilegien
zu nutzen zugunsten von marginalisierten
gruppierungen und
auch im bereich anti rassismus arbeit
auch im bereich aufklärungsarbeit und
ich finde mehr kann man da fast gerade
schon gar nicht tun mein großes ziel und
das ist so wirklich das was an der
spitze steht wäre dass man auf
institutioneller ebene dieses handwerk
sichtbar macht und integriert wirklich
in das friseurhandwerk und es ernster
als ernstzunehmendes handwerk einfach
definiert weil das ist das was jetzt
gerade fehlt weil das würde nämlich
ermöglichen dass sehr viele menschen mit
afrikanischen background die gerade
illegal irgendwo zu hause für hungerlohn
acht stunden lang rasta zöpfe flechten
endlich mal die möglichkeit hätten
ihren beruf auszuüben und dafür eine
adäquate bezahlung zu bekommen das ist
mein ziel und das war immer meine vision
nicht irgendeine kultur zu klauen mich
daran zu bereichern und einfach ignoranz
zu sein sondern eher das gegenteil das
zu wertschätzen und zu integrieren ich
würde dich jetzt einfach gerne eine
halbe stunde weiter reden lassen dann
würden die anderen nämlich wie vor
kritisch sehen du hast es also geschafft
dass alle drei nach vorne gegangen sind
ich muss leider noch mal den bösen
spielen jetzt in dieser geschichte weil
ich weiß sehr sicher auch aus einer
erfahrung aus vergangenen sendungen die
so ähnlich gelaufen sind das jetzt ganz
viele leute an ihrem mobilen endgerät
sitzen und sich fragen was soll ich
jetzt noch mal machen also wieso
also die irgendwie versuchen ein
kriterium einen weg zu finden wie sie
mit dieser debatte umgehen können die
katzen faustregel geben für alle die
jetzt gerade denken ich bin
lernbegierig aber ich bin verunsichert
gibt es eine faustregel
es gab eine faustregel da die werden wir
heute hier nicht finden in dem rahmen da
braucht es einfach noch viel mehr input
auch von verschiedenen noch viel mehr
positionen ich möchte aber gern noch
etwas zu dem thema noch kurz zu
privilegien scheren und sich bereichern
ein gutes beispiel dafür ist und zb sind
asiatischer oder thailändischen
restaurants die ja von zwei
vertragsarbeiter in mühsamen als
nächsten ökonomie als nische aufgebaut
wurden und die aber in eine sackgasse
geendet ist also viele sind einfach
haben einfach ihr restaurant arbeitete
16 stunden am tag und es geht nicht
weiter dann gibt es eben eine weiße
person ein hippes start up in berlin von
zwei weißen
männern und die eignen sich bestimmte
dinge von der asiatischen küche an und
werden aber steinreich davon werden
beruhen werden pionier das ist die frage
ist was ist ein plädoyer war daraus also
diese analyse ist klar ist ein plädoyer
jetzt weiße douglas das mit euren
restaurants oder sagst du weißt du wenn
ihr es schon macht dann sagt wenigsten
wohl jetzt habt also was pro wofür
plädiert also ich plädiere für sehr
teure kriminellen wenn ich jetzt mit
restaurant harbour und ich möchte gerne
filmemacher machen dann gibt doch auch
mal einem japanischen koch die bühne und
oder gibt man einen mexikanischen koch
die bühne und dafür plädiere ich über
einen austausch auf augenhöhe von dem
nicht nur die person der dominanz
gesellschaft profitieren und das auch
wirklich monetär also materiell
hast deinen kanzler nachvollziehen jetzt
gehen wir bei ersten wir haben jetzt
verschiedene beispiele ist mal beim
essen gelandet finde ich ganz gut das
essen das beispiel ist so ein zu oft
dass ich nun wartete dass das darauf
kommt dass wir darüber reden wo ich auch
denke natürlich darf ein türkischer koch
in mexiko ein star werden mit einem
kimchi restaurant dafür und wenn er
damit meint er erfolgreich wird
herzlichen glückwunsch also ich meine
gerade küche ist ja etwas was davon lebt
dass man fusion macht dass man die
tradition übernimmt das man ausprobieren
dass man sachen entwickelt und dass
dinge dann irgendwann tatsächlich auch
nicht mehr einer kultur zuzuordnen sind
was ich halt auch um das zu
unterstreichen was du sagst so
unglaublich gewalt falls ende ist sich
anzugucken wer entscheidet denn nun dass
jetzt alle kämpfe workshops überhaupt
machen das entscheidet wieder der
eurozentrische gaumen entscheidet jetzt
das ist jetzt lecker das ist jetzt cool
das ist jetzt hip für essen für das wir
also
vielleicht
traditionellen afrikanischen aus
afrikanischem essen
vielleicht gingen mit koreanischen essen
der menschen essen wofür man früher in
der schule gemobbt wurde wurde jetzt
entschieden jetzt ist es lecker aber
weil wir ist lecker machen das
wahrscheinlich habt nicht viel ahnung
vom essen wo ich wir sind das am
programm vorher echt nicht wovon er
redet also ich meine wenn es einen
verlierer gibt wieder deutschland es ist
der anbieter von eisbein und sauerkraut
die jungs die da auf diese darauf
spezialisiert waren sozusagen auf
deutsches essen die haben über die
letzten 30 40 jahre wirklich verloren
wer so eine klatsche noch auf macht da
kann sich also seine drei kunden an der
hand abzählen dass jetzt ist immer eine
frage sozusagen seit der mode also ich
war nicht die japanische restaurants in
düsseldorf zum beispiel wo es eine
starke japanische community gibt die
gibt es seit 30 40 jahren da kriegen die
leute hin haben zum teil ein halbes jahr
vorher denn den tisch reserviert und
wissen ganz genau warum sie dahin gehen
also her nicht immer so das mussten 30
40 jahren so das ist die entwicklung
unseres landes und ich kann nur sagen
wenn die beiden also wenn sozusagen die
thailändische küche jetzt im
schnellrestaurant von zwei weißen geist
gemacht hat kavlak warum sind denn der
andere auf die idee kommen immer das ist
nun wirklich eine welt die allen offen
steht warum warum sind das zeigen ja es
waren zwei weiße dies offenbar die die
idee hatten wir fast wieder selber an
die nase und sagt dass man oft warum bin
ich selbst nicht auf die idee gekommen
und das ist ja nicht eurozentrische dass
die sagen wir eurozentrischen leute
entscheiden was jetzt geschmackvoll ist
oder weil es nicht sondern wir alle
miteinander du ich wir alle sagen wo
gehen wir hin und wo gehen wir nicht
schön und so für das kann jeder selbst
entscheiden das ist alles entwicklung im
zuge von kultureller anhalten da kann
ich mir nur wünschen mehr davon ist es
wahnsinn interessant in welcher
auswirkte die diskussion hierüber und
gehen kann es waren wir vorher nicht so
ganz klar dass wir über
solche details aussprechen würden aber
so sind wir nun mal und ihr steht
genauso wie am anfang alle drei jeweils
ganz hinten dass es deswegen interessant
weil wir jetzt in einem kompromiss runde
einsteigen wollen und jetzt wäre es eure
aufgabe also einen kompromissvorschlag
zu definieren um die jeweils andere
seite nach vorne zu locken ich mache mal
einen vorschlag es ist bei diesem thema
wie so oft klingt das vielleicht banal
oder oberflächlich aber ich suche jetzt
erst mal den kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner ja also er ist es jetzt mal alles
zusammenfassen dann habe ich den
eindruck dass die diskussion um das
thema kulturelle aneignung schon
deswegen wichtig ist weil sie
diskriminierungen ans tageslicht bringt
von denen vielleicht eine ich sag mal
pauschal weiße mehrheitsgesellschaft gar
nicht so viel ahnung hat so das ist
schon mal ihren vorteil dass man
überhaupt darüber diskutiert können wir
uns jetzt also darauf einigen dass erst
die auseinandersetzung mit dem
kulturhistorischen hintergrund beim hip
hop bei frisuren bei augen also
wissensvermittlung überhaupt uns in die
lage versetzt wertschätzung dafür
auszustrahlen wenn ihr sagt ja das
stimmt das ist mal das erste was wir
machen müssen dann könnte ein schritt
nach vorne gehen wenn ihr sagt karg
formulierung bleibt da verstehen
okay immerhin also anderthalb anderthalb
leute haben heimlich in die trick du
bist sogar zurückgegangen ich will da
nicht jedes mal wenn ich jetzt einen
kaffee gehe und was mit fremdländischen
namen bestelle die wir vorher den test
machen müssen ob ich auch den
kulturellen hintergrund begriffen habe
vor dem produkt das ich kaufen will ja
sowas auch nicht gemeint ist war ja so
gemeint dann sagt wenn sie das war ein
plädoyer dafür sich mehr als bisher als
es heute passiert mit mit kulturellen
backgrounds ausländer
auseinanderzusetzen dass also eine
bildungsfrage eigentlich wände und
gesagt ist es gut ist mich für andere
kulturen zu interessieren da bin ich
immer dabei mehr als jetzt weil das uns
erst in die lage versetzt zu sagen okay
ich verstehe jetzt erst mal deinen
puncto du hast mit deinen haaren
verbindest du etwas anderes als ich es
hier gedacht habe darum geht's also für
aufklärung bin ich immer
und das ja aber das darf zum beispiel
dazu führen dass man sich unbedingt mit
indischer kultur befassen muss bevor man
ins yoga studio geht jetzt dürft ihr
euch die köpfe zusammenstecken in eurer
gruppe merkt euch bitte eure position
ungefähr und versucht mal eine
formulierung in satz einen appell
loszuwerden um die anderen zu euch zu
ziehen
wir pochen dass das verboten leute
profitieren ja wäre der mensch ohne ihre
also was würdet ihr formulieren um diese
beiden gruppen enger aneinander zu
bringen wir haben ja schon viele
differenzen jetzt gerade gesehen und das
ist vielleicht auch schon meine
erkenntnis aber wie kriegen wir jetzt
die menschen näher zusammen bei dieser
frage ich bin sehr gespannt schreibt
bitte in die kommentare
aber wie heißt das dass du mit schwarzem
aufgewachsen bis zehn millionen weise
aus gesehen auf diesen hinweis gelesen
werden alles käse du bist weiß verdient
wer würde gerne anfangen wollte anfang
habt ihr ein kompromissvorschlag wir
würden uns gern erst die gegen becker
ein
[Gelächter]
wien ein dann müssen wir das ist zum
ersten mal in der geschichte von 13
fragen dass die beiden parteien sich
nicht einigen konnten wer beim
kompromissvorschlag aber so machen wir
das ich so meine münze oder so was hab
ich habe als das plektrum das hat eine
spitze seht ihr das hier es gibt eine
spitze wenn die spitze ich schmeiße
dahin wo die spitzen er in zeigt
derjenige fängt mit der neue die gruppe
kann ja ich werde es einfach hoch
die spitze zeit klar zu euch
ihr sollt bitte anfangen alles klar also
unser kompromiss würde so lauten dass
wir
im komplett von geboten oder verboten
komplett absehen wollen würden und
überhaupt nicht der meinung sind
menschen vorschreiben zu wollen
ob sie sich jetzt ihre haare so
schlechten oder was sie sich anziehen
welches tattoo sie machen das ist
natürlich jedem menschen liegt komplett
frei
oder ob sie ein
erfolgreiches restaurant eröffnen oder
nicht und unser hotel oder unser wunsch
dabei ist einfach noch mal zu bedenken
wem kann ich mit an den tisch holen mit
wem könnte ich meine privilegien teilen
der strukturell einfach benachteiligt
ist es gab bewegung angelina ist wiese
stehen
das finde ich grundsätzlich guten ich
finds nur problematisch dann doch wenn
nicht daran denke dass die erste aussage
von dir war ich würde nicht kunden
werden bei ihr das finde ich dann schon
also dann ist die sind ja nicht ein
präsident ist das dann ist im grunde
genommen dieser vorschlag dieser
kompromissvorschlag schon für mich
eigentlich nicht so rückt wirklich
schließlich auch zwei festen weil auch
anerkennen sie wie sie sagt wir sind
durch den prozess durchgegangen und
jetzt sind wir hier am ende dieses
prozesses ja aber der prozess bedeutet
sie muss sich erst mal stundenlang
erklären wer sie ist was ihre herkunft
ist in welcher bezug sie hat zum
schwarzen zur schwarzen community und
erst dann wird akzeptiert dass sie das
tut und das finde ich ein akzeptables
muss ihn nicht okay wir sind aber jetzt
in der kompromiss 100 der vorschlag
wurde gemacht ich muss nach vorne
gegangen jetzt seid ihr dran wichtig ist
dass wir diejenigen kritisieren die zu
kritisieren sind also diejenigen die
sich lustig machen über augenform
hautfarbe haare was auch immer die
sollten wir kritisieren und die sollten
wir versuchen zu bilden von mir aus auch
zu erziehen aber nicht allgemeine
forderungen zu stellen man sollte das
nicht nur ich finde problematisch dass
weil das ist nicht probleme in meiner
sicht ist es nicht problematisch das
setzt aber voraus ist mein eigenes
verletztheit zumindest überdenken sich
mein mann ist verletzt dass man dann
aber auch wieder sagen okay aber das ist
vielleicht mein persönliches problem
aber ich bin vielleicht verletzt aus
einem ganz anderen grund weil ich
nämlich ständig beleidigt wurde aber
derjenige der jetzt sich die augen auf
eine bestimmte art und weise schminkt
der verletzt mich in weiter gar nicht so
dass es eigentlich derjenige oder
diejenige die mich die sich lustig
gemacht das heißt dass man auch seine
eigene position kritisch hinterfragt mal
um insgesamt wieder ein miteinander mehr
zu schaffen alex christensen war ja
gerade irgendwie die rede von die
richtigen leute erziehen die die
aggressoren sind die die tatsächlich
irgendwie stereotype in form von mobbing
nach außen tragen oder so aber dass das
leugnet die also ein stück weil das ist
eben strukturellen rassismus gibt in
dieser gesellschaft dass auch positiven
rassismus gibt in dieser gesellschaft
und das sind ja alles probleme die
irgendwie zusammen führen zu der
diskussion die wir heute gespielt haben
über kulturelle aneignen deswegen muss
ich sagen
da geradezu gedacht also auch wenn ich
jetzt nicht rassistisch gemacht habe
sind mir meine erziehung in
kindheitstagen auf dem spielplatz und
kindergarten und wo auch immer irgendwie
rassistische stereotype ja auch
verinnerlicht worden und ich habe die
auch verinnerlicht und muss ja auch
daran arbeiten auch wenn ich jetzt keine
aggressor bin oder mich nicht als
solcher aber du fühlst dich als teil
eines strukturell rassistischen rest
genau und möchten an diesem system
arbeiten und an mir arbeiten ich habe
schon glaub ich verstanden was du meinst
aber ich finde es auch okay zum schluss
dann zu sagen
dann trennt uns wirklich was
können wir viele würdigen aushalten ich
kann das an sich auch definitiv gut
aushalten und ist auch so
und ich glaube das ist auch wichtig
pluralität gut aushalten zu können
gleichzeitig frage ich mich einfach
inwieweit ist für dich sozusagen darum
ging tatsächlich dagegen zu sein
ich bin gegen das window sowie das
gesellschaftsmodell was ich natürlich
dahinter witterung wenn du sagst zu
angelina letztlich kann ich in deinem
salon gar nicht gehen weil du bist weiß
was ich nie gesagt was ich kann und ich
wills dennoch also oder so und gar nicht
und gar nicht weil du sagst ich traue
das völlig sofort verstehen ich trau dir
nicht zu dass du mit schwarzen haaren
umgehen kannst das wort gottes willen
also ich lass deiner jeden monat sondern
du bist erst zu einer frage der
identität machst und da glaube ich trend
und da trennt uns ganz viel ich hoffe
trotzdem dass einige sachen und details
klar geworden sind nicht nur allen hier
vor allem die positionen der anderen
sondern hoffentlich auch euch an eure
mobilen endgerät das war 13 fragen
herzlichen dank dafür nach meinem
eindruck geht es bei der ganzen debatte
gar nicht so sehr um eine harte
trennlinie um gesetze was darf man noch
was darf man nicht sondern wie bei so
vielen debatten geht es ganz banal um
wertschätzung wertschätzung von
kulturellen identitäten und natürlich
dürfen und sollen sich kulturen
miteinander vermischen sich gegenseitig
befruchten aber über allem steht die
maßgabe sei einfach kein arschloch
ich finde es gar nicht so schwer wenn
euch 13 fragen gefällt dann könnt ihr
hier unseren kanal abonnieren hier oben
findet ihr ein weiterer folge 13 frage
und hier gibts ein weiteres video zum
thema